- [Instructor] What we have here is just
a small sample of the types of molecules
that you will see in a biological system.
At the top left right over here,
you have an example of an amino acid.
Amino acids are the
building blocks of proteins.
And if we were to take a look
at what an amino acid is made up of,
in this dark gray color,
those are carbon atoms,
in the white, you see hydrogen atoms,
in the red you see oxygen
atoms, and this blue
right over here, that is a nitrogen atom.
And as you can see, a
lot of these elements
keep showing up in
these various molecules,
especially carbon and hydrogen,
but also you see a lot
of oxygen and nitrogen,
and as we're about to
see, phosphorous also
pops up a lot.
Now this isn't a comprehensive list,
you'll also see other elements,
but these tend to show
up fairly frequently.
For example, this is a model of ATP,
adenosine triphosphate,
as we study biology,
you'll see that it's often viewed
as the currency of energy,
the molecular currency
of energy in biological systems.
And once again, we see a lot of carbons
in the dark gray, we see the hydrogens
in this off white color, or the light gray
I guess you could say, you
see your oxygens again,
here the nitrogen is in
this light blue color,
and then you see the
phosphoruses right over there
in that yellow color, phosphorus.
This is a model of a triglyceride,
often known as a fat molecule,
fat molecules are used for energy storage,
and once again, you see many
carbons in the dark gray,
and then you see these hydrogens,
and then a few oxygens.
This is a model of DNA,
a small segment of DNA,
and this is a much more complex molecule
than the other ones we've seen,
in fact, this could extend
far beyond our screen
in either direction.
But once again, you see
these same familiar elements.
You see the carbon in the dark gray,
the hydrogen in that white color,
you see the oxygens in the red,
the nitrogens in the blue, and
the phosphorus in the yellow.
So the big takeaway here is
that biological molecules
tend to be made up of the same set
of elemental building blocks,
and in fact, it isn't just
at the elemental level,
it can even be at the molecular level.
For example, in ATP you have what's known
as a nitrogenous base right over here,
you have a five carbon
sugar right over here,
and you have three phosphate groups,
or a triphosphate group.
In DNA you have something very similar,
the nitrogenous bases are hard to see,
they're kind of the
rungs of the ladder here,
you have your five carbon
sugars, also hard to see,
and then you have these
phosphates as well.
In fact, the backbone of DNA is made up
of these five carbon sugars
and these phosphates.
Now why do these elements keep showing up?
Well these are elements that
you will see a lot in Earth.
For example, nitrogen makes
up most of our atmosphere.
We have a lot of water on
the surface of our planet,
which is made up of oxygen and hydrogen.
Carbon actually makes
up a surprisingly small
percentage of our atmosphere, about 0.04%
of our atmosphere, but
photosynthetic organisms,
like plants, are good at fixing carbon
and storing energy in carbon bonds,
and when we eat those, those
become part of our bodies.
And just to get an appreciation
of what we are made up of,
in terms of elements, we
can look at this chart
right over here where we see that we are
primarily made up of
oxygen, percentage in body,
and that's because we're primarily
made up of water and
water is primarily oxygen.
It also has hydrogen.
Now second to oxygen is
carbon, and then you see
nitrogen, phosphorous, we of
course have a lot of calcium,
calcium of course used in bones,
but it's also used for things
like muscle contractions.
And I could keep on going down this list,
and you will see these other elements
in your study of biology,
but the big picture is
that even though biological systems
can get fairly complex, they're made up
of similar building
blocks, and these elemental
building blocks come from the environment
in which these biological
systems exist and evolved.